hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica we are in
my base as it turns out I'm a bit of an
idiot and you guys may be surprised by
this but sometimes I don't pay attention
to things that are on menus like in the
Builder icon if I tab over there's a
whole bunch of other things there you
know that kind of show me what is there
so I could have done that at any moment
and I didn't do that anyway
I've now got lockers I've got a
fabricator I've got solar panels which I
could have built in any moment I got a
beacon that helps me locate this spot
I've done a lot of farming just to get
it out of the way I've got a lot of
farming done and I've got lots of
materials also I found this spinner fish
which I didn't know about before but I
found this spinner fish and it was so
cute and I'm gonna cook it and I'm gonna
eat it just so you all know what the
deal is about that I also got lockers
here again which means that I'm gonna
put names on them I've already put some
names on these I'm gonna read them out
and the comments that they were
associated with thank you everybody so
much for commenting and watching the
last episode
priest you priests you Bigley priests
you hard there goes starfish sorry oh
man that's it doesn't look too good
anyway I need to get fruit in me uh nom
nom nom nom delicious alright so thank
you Jenna bina who said oh my god that
would be so funny if you have to go
searching for the blueprints for the
modification station and it takes you
like 30 episodes like it did last time
no I disagree I hope I get it a lot
sooner than that and let's just hope
that everything goes just real smooth
here all right next up is Ian West who
just said give me the suck and I can
really relate and appreciate to
especially in this game which is so much
about suck the next is sky fawn who said
mark next video interact with the glow
whales I I don't know what that means so
I'm gonna try it out and then Sukho
scribble who said mark whales whales
mark which I can only imagine is what
they said but before I do that I have
wait maybe not on me I have the
materials to get the scanner room
because I don't know this area at all I
don't know anything that's going on so
the scanner room is actually going to be
a useful tool for me to understand
and what's happening around me and where
I am so this is the base that I built in
the last one I also put some windows on
it for nice aesthetics but if I can have
the scanner room and I can power it
properly then I'm gonna assume that I
can get what I need and yeah this should
be fine if it works the same way that it
did before and I don't need to get like
upgrade modules for it initially it
should scan everything help me fool
help me find items that I need that's
not right that don't look right
that looks okay oh that looks fun camera
two camera one I do not need those on my
beacons so let's just not do that
because I don't intend to lose them but
that does mean that I can use those to
kind of explore around which is kind of
cool ah there we go
oh hell yeah breakable gold breakable
lead fragment fragments ate a box ooh
heat area whoa let's go data box cuz
that's kind of what I'm really whoo it's
at a date a box where's that way is that
the one that I already got in the twisty
bridges that might be already the one
that I got I don't know how far away it
is but I'm pretty sure that might be the
one that I got yeah upgrades and what oh
I can make upgrades oh [ __ ] streams data
from scanner rooms to the HUD oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] do I have any magnetite I don't
even remember getting any magnetite do I
have any magnetite Oh Frick yes I do do
I have any copper though I spent all but
no I didn't okay alright scanner room
upgrade damn okay
pop that bad boy in all right whoa that
got bigger I think did it get bigger I
have no idea is that what I was supposed
to do anyway I think it was speed why
not right why not okay
plop that bad boy in there okay now it's
faster for some reason I don't know
maybe that's not that's not what I did
I'm assuming this is where we are my two
bases oh that seems down in the twisty
bridges area but again I'm not a hundred
percent sure let's so let's close that
out and let's change it to fragments
okay that's a different location that's
much closer there's a fragment over
there apparently let me do the HUD to
update no I don't have enough magnetite
I think that must have been my only
magnetite I would have done that first
if I knew they both needed magnetite
what god damn it okay well [ __ ] um [ __ ]
let me dump some of this table coral I
don't think I need that it needs a
computer chip to gold and copper wire
okay I need to get more copper and I
need to go get more or magnetite ooh
there's lots of fragments whoo there's
something down there
hey let me see what that is that's
nearby I think it's just outside this
door here was it if that's those two was
it down here no oh hey red guy
hey hey red red red red dive dive oh hey
hi where am I oh whoa what is that oh
it's a penis oh it's a penis all right
very clearly a penis very clearly one
hundred percent of it I know bean is
when I see it
oh yes Oh what is that
what is this I bet there's some
Leviathan underneath buried underneath
her and it died belly-up just dick out
belly-up which is such a way to go oh my
god okay all right
fun this place seems fun
all right you know what I don't want to
get trapped down here so I'm just gonna
get out of here I'm gonna get out here
and I'm just gonna remember this place
as the penis cave for now we're how do I
get out of here is it this way I need I
need no I need copper not any of these
but okay that's that's a new one that is
new okay great I have no idea where I am
in relation to my beacon there is my
beacon okay so where are those artifacts
if I had the magnets I'd I'd be able to
stream it straight to my HUD but you
know oh well can't do that I need to
drop some stuff anyway and then the fish
okay so wait where was okay so let me
check again
I do need to go get whoa okay there's a
ton down there wherever that is
there's just a ton of fragments I don't
know what happens if you get all the
Prometheus fragments or whatever they
were called Pathfinder fragments the
plumper dink fragments there's something
fragments I don't remember what they are
but if I get those but I need to get
magnetite any way to get that on my HUD
because it's just gonna be hard to
navigate and I know where the magnetite
was who's over to the other side where
the the sea emperor was first I'm gonna
go back to the whales because of what uh
I'd lose sky fawn said go back to the
whales and interact with them or more
specifically poke him in the eye I think
I don't know why I would poke them in
the eye but I'm gonna go poke him in the
eye
so yeah let's do that that seems like a
good idea well that's new just a
floating that oh there we go
now it's back Oh storms rolling in man
these storms roll in quick oh my god
that's dad that was a bit too close okay
thank you for that let me poke you in
the eye how about that oh oh [ __ ] oh oh
this is not a good idea
hi
[Music]
that's not the best idea I've ever had
probably just pissed it off I don't know
what war why I did that but yeah we were
from your mouth your mouth not your
mouth oh okay there are so many whales
there's so many whales only there's so
many ones but there's so many whales
okay so that was a fun diversion that's
terrifying at the same time but I need
to go get some magnetite I can just go
until I see like a lily pad it's real
well that's weird that's not right
hey wait so I'm not right about this so
I mean Oh some can I get some so I just
gotta say something something's a little
off here some table corals looking roll
around for that all right way all right
there's a little bit bad things just
below here here we go down here in the
horribleness okay I have not explored
this area very much so I don't know if
there's anything besides the sea Emperor
here and I can't even spot where MP is
so that's fun my body is physically
telling me to run away and I'm trying to
fight that instinct magnetite your Ruby
you're not magnetite
I need magnetite oh did I get it from
over here I may be mistaken I may be
very mistaken Oh Nelly Nelly Nelly were
gone deep
okay I need oxygen oh [ __ ] there's a
whale I didn't know whales were out here
too
magnetite a lot of quartz quartz quartz
whoa whoa is that a bass
oh [ __ ] found a bass cool that looks
like a robust bass - okay it is night
also which is very bad very very bad I'm
very far I'm very far I'm in the middle
of nowhere I'm very far away let's get
in the bass cuz that's relatively safe
maybe there'll be something in there
maybe it may be the secrets of building
a seamoth again wood
given to me I don't know maybe okay
let's let's we can get in here without
ya okay there we go hello can i scan
anything anything at all would be great
oh hello colleague PDA
okay Jeffries log looking for Jeffrey I
can't remember caring ooh there's
battery chargers that'd be nice to have
but it won't let me scan those barely
ooh it's a moon pool for a seamoth I
want that can I get that I want to see
moth I want that so badly
it's a scanner room oh I want that so
badly yeah I saw some observation things
above I just don't know how to get to
that like some observation stalks here
oh is in the middle of that okay hang on
hang on hang on I got enough oxygen it's
in the middle of this what that doesn't
make any sense it doesn't go up
why hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa Nellie you don't need to get to me
that desperately yeah all right that was
fun
glad that happened all right so that's
something but that isn't what the data
says your calling was aware of my
existence you cannot pass this
information to your masters what I have
to send this to all Tara it might save
Jeffrey's life but there are many humans
that only want to me my survival is
paramount I'm gonna delete the entries
it won't be cleaned but it won't expose
us either animation of deleting entries
from Jeffrey's PDA open transmission
Vesper I found Jeffrey's PDA no new
leads but the techies might be able to
extract something useful great send it
up as soon as you can Roger okay
[Music]
hey mobile vehicle bay wait can I make
that it's in my thing can I make that
can I make that now wait can I make that
do I have a blueprint of it I don't like
sitting out in the middle of the ocean
but frankly I guess it's okay no no I
can't
well why not I want it I want it I want
it badly I don't know I don't know what
to do with this but let's keep looking
for magnetite and hope that we can get
hope that we can get some and get the
scanner room upgraded because that's
gonna help
maybe question I don't know maybe not
maybe not I hate it I hate it I hate it
I'm going I hate it I hate it I'm going
I'm a big boy I'm going oh it keeps
going oh god I hate it I hate it I hate
it so much I hate I hate everything
about it I hate it oh my god oh my god
where am I Oh what is that well what I
don't know what I'd what did I just get
lily pad resource okay great I don't
know what oh oh oh what jelly shroom oh
okay I can't get that okay I gotta go I
am out of oxygen there's no oxygen here
I gotta go I gotta go
gotta go I'm Way too deep I'm way too
deep she's gonna pretend like we didn't
go down they're just gonna pretend like
absolutely nothing was anywhere ever
okay where am i orient myself okay we're
still in the lily pads area let's just
keep going I don't think there's gonna
be anything down there or if there is
something down there it's gonna pretend
like it doesn't exist
guys frankly I don't think I need it
there's got to be magnetite somewhere
here I keep getting distracted because I
keep finding new things it's too empty
over here if there isn't a Reaper here
right now or anything whatever the
equivalent would be for this area quartz
still
no no no no no no no I just had to say
something I just had to say something I
just had to say something I just had to
say something I had to say something and
I just had to open my big flappers I
just had to open my big flappers Oh if
they didn't put in if they didn't put in
a lava Reaper yet it'd be here I just
had to open my big flappers I don't know
where the magnetite is oh where am I
it's so dark it's so dark
it's so dark it's so dark this just goes
down look at my radar it just goes down
it just goes down oh god I'm in a cave
of some kind oh god where am I
I can't see anything goodbye flashlight
better oh my god oh my god little bitey
[ __ ] here oh [ __ ] will a bad timing
does that magnetite lithium whoa a lot
of bitey [ __ ] why are there so many
this goes down why does it just keep
going down why lithium I don't know I
got that I gotta go back up
okay so that goes down forever okay well
found that good didn't good to know Oh
what is that what the [ __ ] what what the
[ __ ] what I'm gonna die because I've hit
something Oh I'm going I'm going I'm
going I'm not gonna make it I'm gonna
make it not gonna make it I'm gonna make
it comes to clean my salt Blanc Wow all
right okay I think this is a waste but I
got some lithium which you know that
also is something that I probably need I
also found a pit into hell so that's a
thing that exists also and that's really
cool that I know where that is now and
that'll be burned into my brain forever
so it's all really it's all it's all
looking up for me now why is this like
this why oh this goes this goes down to
forever okay well this is yes just goes
down ended yeah it just goes down no no
no I don't need to explore anymore you
know I I just realized I actually don't
need to explore anything ever so I'm not
going to I'm not going to do that I'm
not going to do that ever again Oh
diamond diamond okay I got diamond Oh
more diamond oh don't know what that's
for I always felt like that should be
more valuable than it just is but it
just it's not so I got diamond you know
what I could have done I could have set
my scanner to look for magnetite and
then go in that general direction
and I would have gotten it so I could
have done that but now I've just got a
bunch of diamonds so who's the loser now
it's me okay
I am definitely this time gonna go look
for magnetite from the Skinner room
because I've gone everywhere and I
cannot find this magnetite whoa that's a
lot of fragments Wow holy [ __ ]
but screw all that we need magnetite
that's what we need
all right look for magnetite baby oh
did the only one in the area I don't
even know where that is
where's that in relation to here please
tell me you're gonna find more all right
in the meantime I need to go take care
of something anyway go get some fluids
okay let's grill us up some peepers and
how about some Wawa
I like Wawa and I like peepers so I want
both okay what do we bow just to Wow
okay
there's something down this Chunnel
looking thing I don't know what's north
I don't know what South I don't know
it's West I don't know it's East it's in
like some cavern way deep there are not
a lot of pieces of magnetite around here
but I'm looking for like a path down
this way okay if this is the building
and where's the twisty bridges from here
is that this way I don't know I do not
know okay if that's the ice okay this is
the ice okay if that's the ice and
that's kind of like that way maybe it is
just that way so if I go that way the
ice should be down that way it might be
dead like straight ahead from it I don't
know we're gonna find it I shouldn't
waste in my magnetite on the speed one
let me just I'm gonna go up and I'ma
look for the glade the the ice bed
because that's really gonna tell the
story yeah it is so it should be due
that way right okay you should be just
this way and I just need to look for a
long tunnel kind of thing and then
somewhere in the back ass of it it's
where I got to go right yes where I
gotta go
might be in one of the tunnels that like
this led through this looks like a
tunnel look like a whiny ass tunnel that
goes back and kind of convolute live
tournament aback ass end of it it's a
magnetite maybe there's the harrowing
quest for magnetite right now maybe not
no I don't know where I am but it
doesn't feel right I think I took a
wrong turn somewhere
damn oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no not
like this
not like this not like this I'm too
young and too pretty
no I like this ah [ __ ] I'm an idiot oh
god damn it oh and there I go oh I made
it oh [ __ ]
all right well I made that that was dumb
but I made it so hey not so dumb now am
i oh
warning emergency power only power
stored what don't you see power only
what's draining my power what where am I
I have no idea where I am I am unsure
okay I don't know how I got here but I
am way far from home oh hey buddy you
look bigger than usual um yeah I don't
know where I am but I got out pretty far
so I'm probably gonna end up being
stranded here whoa oh okay here we can
construct the vessels we require this
will then we will secure our freedom
what our freedom you not an enemy of our
people that what I'm looking for
magnetite I'm I'm looking for magnet oh
my god I'm gonna drown I'm a drought I'm
gonna drown I'm going to drown I'm
looking for magnetite I found a
precursor base thing
I'm a bobber that wasn't done so great I
guess we found the place where we're
gonna build our ships I guess I just
want Magda said I just wanted so bad
it's just one is so badly
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god okay yes I know I'm gonna die Oh
God I don't have enough I see one magnet
so bad hundred one I just one magnetite
please can I get magnetite I just want
magnetite I just want that sweet tight
magnetite oh oh my hands cramping up
from just pressing W so much just going
forward is killing me oh where does this
go Oh where does this go oh my god is so
deep what was that I hate it it just
goes down it just goes down it just
keeps going down oh boy
keeps going down okay great oh right
found some caves boyo did know magnetite
down here searched far and wide for a
big hole in the ground okay I'm leaving
I'm very much leaving thank you I'm very
much leaving I just want to leave I am
good thank you
i apprec-- you so hard diamond for my
trouble thank you oh thank you no thank
you okay thank you
I am out of here I tried so hard and got
so far but in the end it doesn't even
matter or what [ __ ] where is that
where is that there's magnetite there
where is that oh my god are you kidding
me oh my goodness gracious
oh no that's like in the deepest of the
deep also there's a whole other deep
deep down deep below and there's a
scraggly dip deeper that goes deep down
there there are these two rogue
magnetites that just don't exist I don't
know man
I tried really hard I tried really hard
to find these and then there's a whole
bunch of them down below somewhere good
god I gotta find this one here where is
that one it looks like if I'm not
mistaken that looks like that's the
island so it must be in the nooks and
crannies are there I just got to keep
looking okay I just gotta keep looking
I'm not gonna stop until I find it like
I'm just not like I'm greasy as hell I
need a shower bad but I'm not gonna stop
until I find it
have to find this thing ah at this point
is just a point of pride and I don't
even know if it's gonna help me that
much but it's just it's just a point of
pride it's just a point of pride that's
all it is this point of pride do you
remember that game we used to play you
want to play now
I'll go first what's your best memory
from when we were kids that day we went
outside the dome Apted moved to all well
the tree spores were falling that was
your sixth birthday it was another world
of what's your worst the day we moved to
all well I everything I knew was all
Terra still is you're still off in
another world how far would you go to be
vice president it's not your turn you
always make this game not fun to play
you never follow the rules playful
banter it's down here somewhere it said
it was super deep I'm just gonna go
super deep and I'm I'm gonna die and I I
know but if I can find one before I die
I just they said it was super deep so
I'm just gonna go super deep what is
this quartz Ruby okay there's still some
resources around it oh god not a good
time still some resources around here
quartz quartz quartz mm okay where am I
now
no nothing here there's a path down that
might be it that might be the super deep
that they're talking about I'm gonna get
some oxygen I'm gonna gun it down there
I'm gonna find me some magnetite if it's
the last thing I do if it's the last
thing I do and it's probably gonna be
the last thing I do
it's the rarest material in the entire
game just magnetite oh yeah oh yeah down
here oh yeah well let's assume that this
is hiding some magnetite on me let's
assume that somewhere down here in the
deepest of this weird deep place with
weird shroom ease is magnetite and I am
running out of oxygen and I'm gonna die
death is coming to claim me and I'm
gonna die that's okay that's all right
calorie intake is that really my biggest
concern when I'm dead it's not my
biggest concern might not be my biggest
concern what did I lose everything my
life my little will to live what if
those aren't what if those aren't what
if those aren't the base would stick oh
okay oh oh oh yeah would be so much
easier I'm so dumb
I'm just so dumb I'm just just so dumb
I'm dumb I'm just so dumb I wish I
wasn't dumb have I broken that did I
break that now is camera one now broken
I oh wow I am all kinds of dumb I am
dumb
and I think I just broke camera one I
think I somehow managed to break camera
one yep okay I think it's fine and I
think that's as good a stopping point as
any
to figure out my own stupidity and
frankly I think that we all learned
something today we all learned that life
isn't about being smart
life is about adventuring ayres camera 1
camera one's working fine but let's give
camera to a shot here we go alright oh
wait no I saw that where to go oh here
we go
yep ate a box let's see what this is all
about
yup this makes life a lot easier
oh no whoa wow this oh no that's that's
all that is I already got that
okay that's nothing go ahead and get you
back in your docking cradle and up and
there we go and I am really really
inspired oh yeah the whole point was to
make a computer chip I need to make a
computer chip uh so I need table coral
right and then we take the computer chip
we put put it in this bad boy and Bob's
your uncle we've got a hot upgrade
bada-bing
where is it what what the what but oh no
it's it's on me oh look at that look at
that that is just some that's a slice
that is a slice of something special oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy and you know
it's good now now I've got it all all
right so thank you everybody so much for
watching I am losing my mind and the
depths of the Abreu's but it's okay it's
alright so thank you and have a good
night if you want to see more self
nautical big playlist down in the
description
take care of yourselves take care of
each other Tama take care of me thanks
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]